hello ladies and gentlemen my name is
Gregory Alba with me is Perry Nemiroff
myself I say right I left the hammer
here that's always a good thing to hold
a knife in here we will survive the
apocalypse
speaking of building things sandcastle
from Netflix has a trailer out I wasn't
even aware of this yeah no one I don't
think anyone really is Harry who you
might know from Collider videos I've
actually gotten a few requests in by
Parian over the past couple months and I
was like wanting really I think you're
awesome yeah you're awesome seriously I
love your slowdown matches I love you
and you're like the most calm when a
Collider Oh everyone's very energetic
but when I'm out in the open when I go
home I'm like a new folks how I made
history
[Music]
[Music]
that door now something that Kate want
to hear you do your job
it's like a very cavil I think so
you look so different you're walking
into something bigger
[Music]
[Music]
Wow I felt since stay in this course we
sit here breaking our backs and we turn
around a few days him for you to go home
we took the problem so
[Music]
[Music]
it's weird watching that after having
just seen what's it called war machine
the teaser for that yeah it's a
completely comedic approach to me yeah
hey Perry go do that thing that people
do when they see a trailer with these
actors you got beast in here Superman
Henry Cavill it just lowers the rates of
the ads quite a bit beyond these he's so
good Mad Max he's great for bodies and
it's not the best movie ever but if you
ever seen kill your friends I want to
see that so good and Glen Powell - I
like him a lot
you ever seen uh scream queens or he's
in hidden figures no no everybody wants
them oh please tell me you've seen
everybody wants them
I can't wait to from Glen Powell first
Fernando Coimbra does ignore a ghost
oh here's your shadow this app Hoosiers
who wanted it it just showed up
Billy Meachem there you go Billy mica I
hope you're happy we're doing this
there's your shadow buddy
I'll be honest about the sandcastles
trailer well it looks like it's hitting
all the right marks of a war movie
you got the action sequences in there
you got the
want you in our economy sequences in
there you got the drama being a
traumatized soldier then you got the
tough soldier who's like just sucked it
all up like Henry Cavill and just doing
his job he's doing what I do I have
nothing but the most upmost respect for
anyone who's ever served in the military
had to go to war or anything like that
but in terms of a movie I don't really
see what looks different about this
specific war it's a fair point
there isn't really some sort of special
hook yeah make you think that you need
to see that above all else except for
the combination of the cast Netflix
value at this point every single time
Netflix says we're putting out a movie
yeah it's gonna make it it's the same
thing with TV - every time a new project
is announced and it's like oh it's going
to you know Fox or NBC I'm like well
that doesn't sound very good but it's
got all the potential in the world I you
know it's it might not be fair but
that's where my mind goes I mean they
did produce Adam Sandler's comedies Oh
No yeah you had to go there yeah I
forgot we're talking about this I'm
pretty sure the ridiculous six is a zero
oh if this was a film being released in
the theaters I wouldn't be like this
looks made-for-tv you saw yeah alongs on
some streaming service it looks like a
legit film that you could see in the
theater so kudos to pulling off a a war
film that has a legit production value
absolutely I'm probably going to see it
regardless of whether or not it has that
huh yeah it's just one of those movies
you gotta just make time to watch I just
paid to go out there pretty soon
there'll be no more movies in the
theater no don't say big Netflix is hell
and pretty soon all the Marvel's films
will be on that foot nice it's gonna be
streaming services and premium theater
going experiences and we're gonna lose
the middle ground it's so sad because
some of the best leaders to go like this
Beverly cinema exactly oh well I hope
those never go away yeah there's a
revenge but then again I wouldn't mind
if everything in the world turned into
an Alamo Drafthouse I'm fine with that
there's that yeah all right I guess I'll
watch the Sandcastle movie Thank You
Billy Meachem for ripping on you know
requesting and I listen to requests
that's what I do I serve
I serve myself read it that's the whole
point of this channel vote okay okay
this is my sandcastle I built meaning
cake crumbles anybody very misleading
tell a children's movie you could
subscribe to the real rejects you can
follow P Nimr off there you go Emma roof
oh I should never announce myself on any
show and I should just walk around with
a recording of you do do people know
your middle name online no no I assure
ya I mean you can you could break the
news you could get the hot scoop her
middle names Logan that is a name that
just got real this weekend yes your
driver's license I don't have it I don't
bring it on me when I Drive with well my
wallets in my car so hopefully otherwise
I don't have a license anymore
PLM that's your yeah anyway Twitter and
Instagram P Nemiroff and you get of
course watches on Collider videos